I want to thank Michael and
congratulations on your re-election as
party chairman that's a big deal
[Applause]
that was a big deal
it's great to be back in North Carolina
very special place very very special
place we've had tremendous success here
we won it twice we won the primaries
twice we won the election twice it was
great sit down come on let's we'll be
with each other we have nothing else to
do tonight
I also want to thank our outstanding
nrcc chair man where is the chairman
Richard Hudson where's the chairman come
on Richard stand up we just got back
from Georgia and he's even a celebrity
in Georgia
we had a great crowd in Georgia too
he's fourth in line for speaker and his
wonderful wife Renee is incredible and
she served four years actually in the
White House says kellyanne genuine here
of kellyanne Conway nobody right
she's so fantastic but thank you and
thank the family your family is
fantastic we appreciate it thanks also
to one of the great stars of the party
one of the great stars in politics
Lieutenant Governor Mark Robinson
[Applause]
and I'm going to endure spark but I'm
not going to tell you about it tonight
okay
we'll save it for another time but you
can count on it Mark congratulations
great job you've been doing a fantastic
job
we also have some Warriors that we fight
together with all the time and we win a
lot we win most of the times
Representatives Dan Bishop was dead
thank you Dan
thank you very much great job
great job we love them
Chuck Edwards chuck chuck
thank you Chuck thank you thank you very
much
and state house Speaker Tim Moore Tim
thank you very much
great job
Tim's doing a fantastic job thank you
for seven years we've been engaged in an
epic struggle to rescue our country from
the Sinister forces who actually hate it
and want to destroy it I really believe
they want to destroy it there can be no
other reason these forces are far
stronger than Russia China North Korea
and Iran all put together because with
the Right leader you saw that just three
years ago
we have the right leader all of those
countries are absolutely no threat
they're not any threat to us we talked
about it before
right now however they are putting us in
the most dangerous position in the
history of our country we've never been
in a position like this there's never
been such Danger
it's because of the Weaponry the power
of the weaponry
and we have people that have no clue
we're people in office
that have no clue together we stand up
to the globalists we stand up to the
marxists
we stand up to the rhinos
because they're very bad
because you don't know where they're
coming from the rain the Rhinos you
don't know where they're coming from we
stand up to the Communists and the
environmental extremists because I'm an
environmentalist I really believe that
we've done some great things for the
environment but you have extremists and
you don't know whether or not they're
really serious about some of this stuff
it's not even believable
we stand up to the open borders Fanatics
destroying our country the radical left
Democrats they're Lawless partisan
prosecutors and the fake news media we
have a lot of it back there but not all
of them are found
that's a big group back there by the way
Dan I think they're here for you maybe
and on November 5th 2024 we're going to
stand up
to the corrupt political establishment
we're going to evict a totally corrupt
president named Joe Biden from the White
House
and we're going to finish
the job that we so successfully started
probably there's been no
more important four years than we had we
did a great job all of us together
things we did nobody thought were
possible
I put everything on the line I will
never yield I will never be deterred I
will never stop fighting for you never
[Applause]
and if I wasn't leading in the polls by
so much we'd have no difficulty
and you know they're the party of
disinformation they say oh we want to
run against Trump in the meantime we got
5 000 prosecutors after us
because they don't want to run against
Trump we beat him the first time we did
much better the second time we beat him
he did much better the second time
more than any other president more votes
than any other sitting president has
ever gotten and more votes in terms of
the margin from 63 million and add
millions and millions no presidents done
that usually they get less the second
time you know you get tired of them they
weren't tired of me because we got many
more votes with your vote we will take
back our country from these fascists and
thugs
and we will indeed make America great
again
[Applause]
from the beginning
our America First agenda has been an
existential threat to the rotten
political class that gets rich and
Powerful at your expense erasing our
borders cheating like we've never seen
before in elections
exporting our jobs and squandering our
blood and treasure on endless Foreign
Wars we didn't start any wars first time
in 71 years no Wars they all said Trump
will get us into a war he's got that
personality no it was my personality
that kept us out of wars
though we finished some Wars we finished
Isis one hundred percent of the
caliphate we knocked out Isis we did
whatever we had to do and we were
respected all over the world as Warriors
without having to fight Wars you know it
doesn't fight too many wars China you
ever noticed Soul talk it's beautiful
military
they try and beat you economically not
militarily and there's something very
smart about that isn't there
but they respected us they respected
your president and they respected our
country they no longer respect us
and it's very sad what's happening
they've launched one hoax
these people we have to deal with
and they've launched Witch Hunt after
Witch Hunt
and they just tried to stop our movement
they want to do anything they can to
thwart the will of the American people
it's called election interference that's
what they're doing now this is election
interferes
and we've never seen it on a scale like
this
and you have to understand the other
side is downright crooked
that's why we now call them
crooked Joe Biden because you know we
took the name away from Hillary she
suffered enough with that name
so I retired the name from Hillary
because I want to bring it over to Biden
because he's probably worse than she
ever was I'm not saying something
as the Durham report proved they spied
on my campaign they forged false
evidence to get illegal surveillance
warrants the FBI offered one million
dollars for a fictitious dossier written
by a foreign spy to try and frame me for
treason we beat it all off didn't we
they put our country through hell and
they knew it was a lie the entire time
they knew it was a lie they knew the
laptop from hell was alive they knew
everything
remember it's not me
they're going to go after
and if you think of it
whoever took my place and I hope it's
not going to be anybody because we're
the ones that are going to save this
country because our country is in
trouble
they'll go after that person and that
person will not be able to withstand the
fire and I know all of them
I know them all and they actually admit
it they come to me how do you stand this
and I usually look at them and say in a
sick way I sort of enjoy it
because
it exposes them
it exposes them for what they are and
it's also lifted the poll numbers to
even higher legs have you seen this the
polls are through the roof and the
fundraising small dollar fundraising is
setting records
but still
you get indicted over nothing you get
indicted over the presidential records
act which they don't even admit they
call it the Espionage Act
these are sick people
we had Russia Russia Russia Ukraine
Ukraine Ukraine the no collusion Mueller
Witch Hunt
impeachment hoax number one remember the
perfect phone call
impeachment hoax number two
the illegal censorship of the hunter
Biden laptop from hell
the 51 intelligence officials who
falsely said it was Russian
disinformation remember they said that I
said nobody believes that who would
believe that you see the pictures
horrible pictures
the real pictures haven't been exposed
yet
but all of this and it just kept coming
and coming and coming and it would for
another
person in my position but they wouldn't
be able to handle it they wouldn't be
able to take it because you're dealing
with crazy lunatics
now the Marxist left is once again using
the same corrupt doj and the same
corrupt FBI
and Attorneys General and Local District
Attorneys to interfere in our election
at a level that our country has never
witnessed before these criminals cannot
be rewarded they must be defeated we
have to defeat them soundly
in the end they're not coming after me
they're coming after you and I'm just
standing in their way
the baseless indictment of Me by the
Biden administration's weaponized
Department of Injustice
will go down as among the most horrific
abuses of power
in the history of our country I think it
already is when you think about it
and certainly going back to Obama when I
said you know they spotted my campaign
everybody including the fake news media
back there they said oh that's so crazy
it turned out I was right
this vicious persecution is a travesty
of Justice
you're watching Joe Biden try to jail
his leading political opponent think of
it this is like third world country
stuff trying to put his opponent who's
leading him by a lot
wants to put him in jail
over following a civil act this is a
simple thing the presidential records
act It's all under the presidential
records act as it should be It's all
under the Clinton Sox case you know what
the Clinton Sox case is that's where
they sued Clinton and he ended up
winning that he could keep
the things that we're talking about it's
all under that Mr Congressman we
discussed that before
but this is more like stalinist Russia
or communist China that we're dealing
with these people
have reached a level of trump
derangement syndrome that nobody thought
was possible
and I never thought frankly that this
could
happen in America
you go after a president that got again
the most votes by far of any sitting
president in history gets out of office
and because I'm running if I wasn't
running wouldn't even be talking about
it if I weren't leading
we wouldn't be talking about it but
we're leading by a lot we're leading to
sanctimonious by
massive numbers he's he's heading south
quickly no personality you've got to
have a personality to win
he's got no personality
and you know remember that
when he came to me he had virtually no
votes he was dying as the expression
goes he was a he was dead
I said George Washington could endorse
you it wouldn't matter no sir have you
endorsed me I'm telling you I'm going to
win I said let's give it a shot I
endorsed him he went up like a rocket
ship and shortly thereafter they had the
primary
and he won and then we had to get him
through
a crackhead
but nobody knew he was a crackhead at
the time at the time he was the hottest
politician in the Democrat Party male
version
female version Stacy Abrams
that's true Stacy Abrams
and him
and but he was hard to beat and Ron said
to me I don't think I can beat him I
said you'll beat him you'll beat him and
I did
three rallies massive massive massive
rallies thousands and thousands of
people
and I said you're going to win and he
ended up winning
and then they started cheating at the
end you remember all the votes were
disappearing over days ten thousand here
Rick's got same thing and I called in
you wouldn't believe if the FBI would
you believe it
and it stopped so at least they did
something right
but I got him in and then they said to
him
I say congratulations Ron I didn't know
him that well he was one of the many
people that supported me during the
impeachment hoaxes so I'd see him on
television a little bit but I didn't
know him well then I heard three years
later they said would you run against
the president
and he said I have no comment that means
he's gonna run
I said I got this guy in Mr congressman
and he said he's going to run
and then I haven't been very nice to him
since then
but we're leading in Florida by
28 points
and people are not happy with him and
he's a lousy campaign to remember that
when he came to see me he had almost no
points he was ready to look for a new
career you told me that better than
anybody he was looking for a job
and when I endorsed him it was like
magic it was like he was a rocket ship
but I believe in loyalty and you know
it's just very disloyal if somebody got
me into office and I got him in you know
some people I help
some people I help and some people I get
and I got this guy and along with some
others but some people I help and that's
different some people I I help a little
bit some people I help a lot but some
people I get in I got this guy in so you
know you think there'd be a little bit
of a loyalty and it's bad for the
Republican Party frankly but let's see
what happens
but we're leading by a lot but meanwhile
Joe Biden and
had troves and troves thousands of
boxes classified documents from his time
as vice president
and even as a senator and boy when
you're a senator and you take classified
documents that's a big deal I watched
Dick Durbin get so angry about it I said
well he'll be brought back into the fold
eventually but he went out and Senator
Durbin he said you can't as a senator
take
classified documents out of his skiff he
took him out of a skiff as a senator
it's unheard of
I spoke to a lot of senators they said I
don't believe a lot of them got a lot of
them they didn't believe it
and they come after me
and we had a great we had a wonderful
operation everything by the presidential
records act we were talking to Nara
but you know nara's radical left do you
know they have a red flag on the
Constitution of the United States
and in the Bill of Rights you know what
red flag is it is a dangerous document
this is where Nara is coming from
and uh
they're very really they've done
I would say over the last number of
years very poor job but they're very
very radical left so you have to be
careful of these people but they
conspire with the FBI they can Inspire
with it it's just a crazy situation I
mean that this country goes through if
we could devote the same Brilliance to
making America great again to fighting
Russia to fighting China to fighting all
these people that are eating our lunch
like China we did a great job with China
I took on hundreds of billions of
dollars in taxes and tariffs from China
think of it no other no other president
took in any money any money not not two
dollars
but many of Biden's documents
were in Chinatown DC you know that you
know what Chinatown DC is that's that's
the real deal
that's the place
and he's getting money based on reports
currently and of the media the fake news
was doing their job they'd be
earning Pulitzer prizes which no longer
mean anything you know I'm suing the
Pulitzer Foundation you know that
because
they gave Pulitzer prizes
to reporters from The New York Times And
The Washington Post
because of their wonderful and accurate
reporting on russia-russia Russia but
they were wrong
in fact the Durham report just said how
wrong they were but they were but we
knew that even before the Durham report
many of them have already conceded the
fact that they were wrong
and they have Pulitzer prizes
we want those prizes taken back
and we want them maybe reissued to other
people like
like Greg Jarrett
like John Solomon like all these people
that actually did call it right they
were real reporters they really did a
great job
but they have to take those back and so
we're suing them and we're suing them
for damages because they're liabeling me
by saying that these people
continue to have the Pulitzer Prize that
means they're saying that the story of
Russia Russia Russia which even the
papers themselves have now admitted is a
hoax
that's labeling me because they're
saying that it continues to exist so
let's see what happens with that but we
have to bring back our country we have
have to bring back sanity into our
country you know the media is so
important they could straighten things
out so badly
so quickly look if 15 years ago
15 years they're like a policing agent
they should be 15 years ago 10 years ago
if somebody said that somebody was
taking money from China and from Ukraine
and from all these other places
tens of millions of dollars
they would all be rushing to try and get
the story
Woodward and Bernstein I'm not a fan of
either one actually I got to know my
major sleaze bags but
you know Woodward looks like such a
wonderful guy he's absolutely the worst
what's leads for example poor Richard
Nixon he did he he had to put up with
them but I got my own problems with
these people
but Woodwards of slaves Bernstein I
don't know but he looks pretty bad to me
I don't know Bernstein I heard he was
the he was the poorer of the two he
seemed to be that nasty person for a
person that doesn't know me I don't
think I ever met him but if I did it was
quick but he's a nasty guy
but they're all nasty because they're
deranged
but we have to have our
great media be policing agents so that
things like this can't happen
because you know there is no Scandal
without press if the Press refuses to
write that Joe Biden got five million
dollars and a lot of other things are
coming out this week then they can't
really be a scandal when you think of it
right they can't be
[Applause]
Jamie Comer and Jim Jordan have been
incredible and the whole their
committees but you know it's amazing
that they sometimes say to me not the
two individuals but people in the
Committees and people in Congress were
talking about it just a little while ago
with a few congressmen
we have stuff that's so Earth shaking
and you put out the announcement and you
think it's going to be headlines in the
New York Times And The Washington Post
on every paper and every ABC which is
real fake I call it ABC fake News NBC
fake news CBS fake news
but you put it oh I put fake in front of
every one of them
and nobody can say it's not it's like
they're coordinated they're totally
coordinated they use a word like they
had a word not so long ago manufactured
the votes are manufactured every station
said the same thing it's never been used
in politics before nobody ever said
votes are manufactured every one of them
I'm going to report that the votes have
been manufactured you turn to the next
one ABC the votes have been managed it's
like somebody sends them a memo what to
say but if they were on us our country
would be in such great shape
amazing but they're not
it's no coincidence they indicted me the
very same day it was revealed that the
FBI hit explosive evidence that
Joe Biden took a 5 million dollar
illegal bribe from Ukraine now this is
done I haven't read anything about it
this would have been the biggest story
in history 10 years ago
Walter Cronkite would have reported it
and he was on the liberal side to put it
mildly but he would have made this the
biggest story but we don't have Walter
Cronkite anymore do we Walter Cronkite
the Walter Cronkite said the great ones
are gone
right as they're closing in on Hunter
and Joe Biden
they want me to
put up with this form of Retribution
like nobody's ever seen before but it's
okay because the public is smart you
know it's amazing how smart the public
is I go through the town I was always
doing well and people liked me and we
did great with the you know all the
votes we got the most ever for sitting
president but I was doing great I've
never had receptions we just left
Georgia
and we had a room that was I mean
they've never had anything like it and
there were thousands and thousands of
people outside trying to get in for the
Republican Chairman's lunch not normally
the biggest thing now because Michael is
so outstanding of course this is a big
deal
but but you've never seen the streets
tremendous crowds at the airport waiting
the airport being very far away from the
venue where it was people all along the
roadway and this is not really campaign
season people are disgusted with what's
going on in our country they want
America back they want America back
[Applause]
so I've been predicting this for a long
time just like I did with live you know
live golf I told the players take the
money to Rocco and me say thank you very
much
should I take 185 million dollars say
yeah take it
but sure that means I have to leave the
tour don't worry about it take it
because three things are going to happen
they're going to merge which I predicted
they would and it was nice they actually
covered me very well they said it was
like really good but they're either
going to merge or they're going to be
successful
in one case got 185 million dollars
great one Dustin
great player Dustin Johnson
Brooks kepka these guys we're you know
they're great but you know
lots of others were offered hundreds of
millions of dollars they said no and now
there's a merger and I actually made the
statement I said if there's a merger and
you don't take the money you're gonna
have a lot of very unhappy golfers out
there
and you have a lot of very unhappy
golfers out there but it was exactly as
I said
but I called this one too
and
I said that Hunter will
probably be charged with some minor
offense like jaywalking
so that the FBI and the doj can pretend
that they're Fair
oh we got Hunter so while they're going
after me under the Espionage Act
that's like the creation of missiles in
your basement
they got him for nothing
and there's never been a more corrupt
group of people in the history of our
country running this country
where somebody sits on a board gets 83
000 a month a three million dollar
upfront payment
nobody's ever said anything like this
and in all fairness was interviewed on
one of the shows
on
main television I call it Maine used to
be
serious television now it's main
television
but he said uh no I don't know why they
paid me so much do you have expertise
sir and
oil and gas it's an oil and gas company
no I really don't do you know anything
about it no
then why are they paying you 83 000 a
month and three million dollars in
upfront payments so we think it's
actually more than that
but these are corrupt people
these are corrup he had no answer
he had no answer
the money laundering the
ignoring bribery and the other massive
crimes
they all implicate crooked Joe Biden
see how good that name works because you
know Hillary's now finished let's assume
although she's probably going to try and
make a comeback after this speech she'll
probably try but I don't think she'll be
very successful but she was a woman that
was out of control
the stakes of this election could not be
more Stark either we have
a communist state you know they used to
use the term deep state I'm stopping it
I'm using it Marxist I'm using it
fascist I'm using Communists Because
deep state is far too soft
[Applause]
remember during the campaign I'd say
we're going to end up being another
Venezuela but on steroids big scale
version big large beautiful scale
version of Venezuela how about we're
buying oil from Venezuela
when I left Venezuela was ready to
collapse we would have taken it over we
would have gotten to all that oil it
would have been right next door
but now we're buying oil from Venezuela
so we're making a dictator very rich can
you believe this nobody can believe it
you know where the well you know their
oil is garbage it's horrible the worse
you can get tar it's like tar and to
refine it you need special plants and
these people are talking about not doing
our we have liquid gold the best most
beautiful stuff you can get liquid gold
better than gold right under our feet we
have more than
Saudi Arabia we have more than Russia
we were going to have the greatest
greatest Energy System in the world
we're going to pay off debt we're going
to reduce taxes we're going to make so
much money that these guys came along
and they stopped it all what we had done
is
what we had done is amazing but with
Venezuela they put their oil and they
refine it in Houston
so all of those pollutants go right up
in the air
we don't want to take oil because we
want to watch the environment but we'll
take the worst car in the world burn the
crap out of it create oil and watch it
go into our atmosphere
so the environmentalists have no problem
with that so we lose economically and we
also lose from an environmental
standpoint because it is really dirty
stuff the dirtiest stuff you can imagine
we take it from Venezuela and we also
make the country strong again
and the head of the country is a
dictator
it's not even believable some of the
things that are happening open borders
who would believe open borders who would
believe no voter ID I want to vote oh go
ahead and vote
that's why they have all these people
coming and they think they're going to
be able to vote the funny thing is a lot
of them turned for Trump
you know a lot of them on the Texas
border towns wouldn't that be funny we
like Trump the best
we like Trump
that the governor of Texas called me
right after the election he said you've
done something that's unprecedented you
want every single town along the border
mostly Hispanic he said that hasn't
happened since he called it
reconstruction I said is that Civil War
would you say that Civil War that Civil
War you know you know term we haven't
heard in a long time reconstruction but
hadn't happened since reconstruction
Civil War
but it happened we did incredible we're
doing incredible with Hispanics at the
end of the day either the Communists
destroy America or we destroy the
Communists
and never forget what the demented
persecution of our movement
is all about our enemies are desperate
to stop us because they know that we are
the only ones who can stop them we're
the only ones that can do it small group
relatively small group
but we couldn't stop them called and we
will and we would have had him stop cold
and they know that and they cheated like
dogs they cheated like nobody's ever
cheated before you turn on your
television at 10 o'clock you would have
said Pennsylvania is a lock
we were up by so much I lock all of a
sudden you see that big fat dump that
big dump at 302 or whatever it was in
the morning it's a disgrace what
happened
what's happening to our country is a
disgrace but I promise you this
if you put me back in the White House
their rain will be over and America will
be a free Nation once again
[Applause]
thank you very much
I stand before you today as the only
candidate
who has what it takes to smash this
corrupt system and to truly drain the
swamp
and I'm the only one that they don't
want to do it and again that's why
disinformation we want to run against
Trump
we want to run oh we're dying to run
against
we killed them last time they know it
killed them with Hillary how about that
one you think that was a little surprise
That Shook them up they said we'll never
let that happen again so they developed
all sorts of read the New York Times I'm
not a fan of the New York Times but read
New York Times certain stories but read
in particular Time magazine cover
from a couple of years ago because they
couldn't
help themselves they had to take credit
for it what they did was so bad for our
country and look at our country now look
what we are we're dying
anyone else will be ripped to shreds
there's no issue where
a spine of Steel is more important than
when it comes to rescuing America from
a really bad Biden economy our economy
is sick everything is sick
but remember and it's true 100 percent
they will not be able to withstand the
fire
for three years Joe Biden and his
corrupt allies in Washington have waged
economic Warfare on the hard-working
citizens of our country
Biden flooded your communities with
millions and millions of illegal aliens
look at what's happening to our country
right now
crushing American wages and stealing
American jobs I believe that you don't
hear this number I think from anyone
else I Believe by the end of this year
the real numbers 15 million people
that's bigger than New York State
will have come in
to our country
he launched a vicious crusade to shut
down American Energy
Anwar
think of Anwar in Alaska Ronald Reagan
couldn't get it done nobody could get it
done so many years so many decades I got
it done
the first day they terminated Anwar
would have been bigger than Saudi Arabia
at least the same size would have been
bigger so good for Alaska
would have been the biggest in the world
we were going to make so much money
we're going to pay off our debt
we're going to reduce your taxes still
further remember I gave you the biggest
tax cuts in history the biggest
regulation Cuts in history
but we would have made so much because
oil and gas is such a big business such
a big big business such a powerful
business and such an important business
New England
as a liberal tint but we're taint I
would say taint is a better word
actually but it it's a little bit on the
liberal side they say but they pay the
highest energy prices in the United
States because they're afraid to build a
pipeline right through New York state in
a poor region where people desperately
need the pipeline would bring down New
England numbers by 50 or 60 percent
but nobody wants to talk about it
Biden spent trillions of dollars on
socialist lunacy causing the highest
inflation in 52 years
since Biden took office the typical
family has lost over stink of this
seven thousand four hundred dollars of
annual each year income
job
his number one job was
as next president what he wanted to do
he just everybody that talks in there
right we want to reverse
what Joe Biden's done he's been a horror
show economic horror show he's been a
horror show from the standpoint of our
country
and what he's done in terms of
our military he's given away 85 billion
dollars worth of equipment
the best equipment in the world to
Afghanistan they're now one of the
leading sellers of military equipment
anywhere in the world some people have
them at number two because they don't
need seven hundred thousand brand new
Rivals
they don't need 70
000 Vehicles many of them armor plated
think of your friends that have a used
car lot and think of them as big that
big if they have 300 cars in that lot
it's a lot we gave away 70
000 some of them costing millions of
dollars Vehicles armor plated four
inches of armor
under my leadership we built the
greatest economy in the history of the
world in fact we did it twice
and now we're going to dig again and
it's going to be better than ever we're
going to do it again
as president I ended years of bitter
betrayals of North Carolina workers
North Carolina was hit very hard by the
Democrats
I withdrew from the job-killing
trans-pacific partnership would have
killed your state
a globalist Calamity that would have
killed American Manufacturing
forever I stopped it I ended it
it was a disaster
known as NAFTA I killed NAFTA nobody
thought it could be done you know you
had to get it killed through Congress
you helped a lot Mr congressman
who was the worst trade deal ever made
nobody thought because you have people I
don't know where they get their thinking
but you know they get it from
lobbyists and lots of other people and
it's hard to get the votes even when
something is
really good
and we replaced it with the U.S MCA
that's the Mexico Canada
trade deal and you know how I know it's
good because they are working feverishly
to try and renegotiate the deal because
they're getting killed by that deal and
I just hope the Biden Administration
doesn't do it because we suffered with
NAFTA for decades dafta was the most
unfair was the worst trade deal probably
ever made
I stood up to China like no
Administration has ever done before
bringing hundreds of billions of dollars
pouring into our treasury from China
when no other president had gotten
anything from China they never got
anything
they got a lot of that's what
they got
and when China targeted our Farmers I
got China to get
28 billion dollars who do you think else
is going to do you think Joe's going to
do that hey
president XI you've really been screwing
our Farmers you got to give us got 28
billion for the farmers that's why I say
I'm not losing Iowa
somebody said how are you doing in Iowa
I am up like 35 points but I said how
could I lose Iowa I got 28 billion for
the farmers in Nebraska any Farm state
you were you took some big chunk out of
that 28 billion too by the way when I'm
back in the Oval Office I will revoke
China's most favorite Nation trade
status
and remember they got that because they
said they were developing Nation well
you know what honestly we're developing
Nation our cities are going to hell we
have to redevelop our cities or our
country is going to hell
look at our cities look at New York and
Chicago and Atlanta Atlanta has the
highest crime rate per capita of any
City Atlanta
where they're trying to get me on a
perfect phone call
people kill people and they never even
get interviewed but let's get Trump on a
perfect call a call that was so good it
was actually better than my perfect call
with the Ukrainian precedent so Linsky
it was more perfect
but think of it I have many lawyers on
this call just to diverge I have many
lawyers on this call state lawyers
Brad rathensberger was of the call I was
calling to complain about the election
because I said it was rigged and had
good reason
but we were there many lawyers I said
things that was that the call ended
future calls were going to be and nobody
said sir you shouldn't say what you just
said what a horrible thing
what I said was perfect it was actually
perfect could not have been better most
people have read it they've said oh
what's wrong with this it's just a con
job
they can't they're all disinformation
misinformation secunda
if there were a problem with that call
these state lawyers would have said sir
you're not allowed to say that would you
please take it back
this came up long after that call was
made
it's like John Lovitz remember John
Levitz on Saturday Night Live he's
probably a trump hater but I'll use his
name anyway the liar they called him the
liar yeah yeah I went to Harvard that's
where I went I went to Harvard I'm a
businessman that's right I'm a business
man
well they did it too they said let's see
there was a call with Trump that's right
there was a call yeah I think he said
some let me tell you
if
if there was anything said wrong in that
call
they would have been screaming
from the rafters how dare you say that
sir you're not supposed to that girl was
perfect I complained about election
fraud and I wanted them to do something
about it and they should have done
something about it but they didn't
we will gain total independence from
China we will make the United States the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we were starting to do that
tremendous money was coming in and to
your state it's coming into
who's coming into
North Carolina what a what a place under
Biden we've
had record high trade deficits which I
call losses a lot of people don't say oh
a trade deficit isn't a loss I call it a
loss
some people don't I understand they're
thinking I was a very good student at
the Wharton School of Finance can you
imagine I wonder if they're proud of me
I got indicted I wonder if they're
saying oh that's wonderful
I've been indicted twice now in a couple
of months
you know when I was studying and when I
was uh very very successful businessman
then I did The Apprentice and I did lots
of books that were big big big big
sellers even now I have books that are
tremendous sellers I never had
I never had this stuff in mind I never
had the word indictment what's
indictment mean sure that's when you're
extremely dishonest sir
no these people are con men and we have
deranged people running it
for this reason I will pass Landmark
legislation
because we have to save our country to
be known as the Trump reciprocal trade
Act
you know what that is when China charges
us a 150 percent tariff
we charge them a 150 percent right now
they charge us
right now so we charge them nothing they
charge us 150 percent
so I said to one of our
terrible Senators guy named Tumi Pat
Toomey real Beauty I said and he was all
in for you know he called it free trade
it's not free trade stupid trade very
stupid trade we call it we have a new
name we've developed a new name
stupidray I said Pat so let me ask you
John is charging us 150 percent
tariff on various products can we charge
them a hundred no sir it's not free
trade I said how about a hundred percent
they're at 150 what about no sir you
can't do that what about 50 you know sir
what about 10 Pat no sir you can't do
that that's not free trade these are the
dumbest people I've ever seen
it's called an eye for an eye or a
tariff for a tariff
but isn't that a beautiful thought
because we're getting screwed by every
country in the world
and I need to get this one approved by
Congress
and they prove things easy if they're
bad things if they're not politically
correct they don't want to do but this
is politically correct this is very
simple they charge us we charge them
what's going to happen is a lot of them
will come off
because they're saying what's the use of
us collecting 150 if they're going to
get 100 so it's coming but some won't do
that and that's okay because we'll take
in a fortune but we'll make Trade Fair
in a day really in addition because
we're the pot of gold but we're rapidly
losing that pot of gold status soon
we're not going to have anything
we're losing so much money in addition I
think we should have about a 12 to a 15
tax on anybody that comes into the
United States this is a tariff if they
want to do business if they want to take
our wealth if they want to steal our
wealth from us they should pay 15
percent
it's not that high a number it's not
going to stop them we'll make a fortune
and we're going to become a prophet
making machine so easily
actually
because remember we have 34 trillion
dollars in debt got to pay it off
and we don't want to do anything stupid
but if we do the reciprocal trade act
that's fantastic and if we do a uh you
know we've had people smart people that
said if we are going to sell our wealth
to other countries we should charge them
for it why should we allow other
countries to come in and steal our jobs
to make our cars
to make our computers to make everything
and then just sell them right back at us
with no tax no I think if we do that
they should be charged 15 percent
the numbers that you're talking about
are astronomical and we will become
overnight a tremendously successful
country and many jobs when you do that
will come back into the United States so
I want you to think about that that'll
be very controversial tomorrow in the
fake news because it's such a good thing
they're gonna hate it
we're going to fight the globalist
vultures and the Washington swamp just
as we did before and we're going to win
we're going to have tremendous victories
I said we're going to beat Hillary I was
right I said we're going to be
Biden I was actually more right
but we're going to beat him this time
and we're going to watch those votes
you know with covid you couldn't go
there you people sent in the votes to
get all these ballots they send in the
votes millions of tens of millions of
votes coming out going in nobody knew
what the hell they knew what was
happening
but we can never let that happen again
remember this Jimmy Carter
and he's a nice man and I know he's not
well so I'm not going to say anything
but Jimmy Carter had a commission and he
said you can't do a mail-in ballots if
you have mail-in ballots it's going to
be Rife with fraud
of course it's going to be Rife with for
people are getting seven ballots eight
ballots ballots
and we can't do it can't do it we're not
going to have a country left France used
to do it they got out of it because they
said it was so fraudulent and they went
to paper ballots same-day voting voter
ID and you know what they had an
election they got 36 million votes
they had a winner they had a loser and
that was the end of it
very simple a lot of people you know it
sounds
too simplistic but paper ballots they
make certain Watermark paper that's
phenomenal stuff it's actually
technologically advanced paper if you
can believe it but we should do paper
ballots we should do voter ID and we
should go back to same-day voting we
should also have what just one day
we don't need even if you call it a
holiday we don't need to have you know I
don't know if you know this we don't
need to have
48 days of voting
[Applause]
and just remember they created a lot of
ballots
they had places where there were
more ballots than there were voters
and had a hard time explaining it but
the courts don't like to get involved
because the courts were not courageous
they were not courageous it's a shame
what happened but we have to have strong
elections and we have to have a strong
border it's no wonder the swamp is
getting truly desperate as they see us
leading big in all the polls in this
week's morning console poll just came
out we have a 34 point lead onto
sanctimonious
we're at 56 percent
that's with a lot of people in it
Haley's at three
great job
Pence is at seven
oh look at this one this one just came
out in the clarity campaign poll very
respected
we're leading by 56 points that doesn't
mean we have 56 that means we're leading
Ronda sanctimonious by
56 69 for Trump 13 for the Sanctus
and Pence Essex you know once you get
used to saying to Sanctus it's hard to
say to Santos I was actually being
interviewed I was trying to be serious
and I called them the Sanctus I said
that's not good but he's changing his
name you know now it's DeSantis
and I put a little message out never
change your name in the middle of a
campaign
you don't change your name in the middle
of a campaign
in the Emerson poll of Iowa we're
leading by 42 points see I told you I
told you
I got him 28 billion dollars how are we
gonna lose
that's a big lead in Iowa we're going to
do great in Iowa we've always done great
in Iowa and we're leading Biden by a lot
in the recent Fabrizio swing state poll
of Arizona Georgia Michigan Pennsylvania
Wisconsin
we're in almost 50 percent of the vote
already
and we're leading Biden by five which is
a shocking you know you would think
you'd be leading them by 40.
you would think it would be leading him
by more than we're leading the Sanctus
in the ABC Washington Post poll
just came out I'm up by seven points
over Biden
and the new poll from
democracy Institute
very respected shows that I'm the only
candidate that beats crooked Joe Biden
and DeSantis is losing to him by a lot
with each passing Day More Americans are
joining our patriotic movement
we are having unbelievable success
only Garnet even further by what's
happening because
what they're doing is so bad for our
country people are saying you can't
weaponize you can't do this
together we've achieved more than anyone
thought even possible we delivered the
largest tax cuts in history we delivered
the largest regulatory Cuts that's why
we had the greatest
employment numbers ever in history we
achieved energy Independence we were
soon going for energy dominance where as
I told you before we're going to be
paying off massive amounts of debt and
lowering your taxes still further
because that's the kind of numbers
you're talking about when you get the
oil cooking
in 60 years think of it we had the worst
the worst problems and the worst costs
in energy in 60 years we headed down to
a dollar 87
three and a half years ago a gallon and
we actually had it lower than that but
we won't even talk about that because I
had to save the oil companies they were
all going to go bust I said this is the
first time I've ever said we got to get
it up a little bit I actually called
Russia and the king of Saudi Arabia we
had a three-way call
and we cut back on the oil because it
was so incredible help fill up the
Strategic National reserves and he's now
taken all of that to reduce
gasoline prices for cars just prior to
the election very artificially
and is reduced it down to the lowest
level that it's been in I think 60 years
we created the most secure Border in U.S
history built hundreds and hundreds of
miles of border wall
was going to build another 200 miles to
fill up some gaps that we saw
and then they
came in after a very strange election to
put it I'm trying to be nice
a very strange strange election really
bad election but they came in and they
didn't want to fill up those walls and
that's the first time I said these guys
actually want to have open borders
we got Mexico to give us 28
000 soldiers free of charge that's how
we succeeded you know we had the most
secure Border in the history of our
country
part of it was I got Mexico we built the
wall large sections of the wall we got
Mexico free of charge and I like the
president of Mexico a lot he's a
socialist but as the expression goes you
can't have everything but I like them a
lot
but I said to the people over in the
state department I said give me a list
of the 10 top things you would like
and one was to have their soldiers
helping us
with the people coming in you know
they're coming in through Mexico and
they gave me a list of 10 and the woman
who was really a pro but she was just a
little bit naive she said sir you're
never going to get this we've been
trying to get this I've been here for 25
years we've been trying to get this for
25 years you're never going to get
unless you want to make a little bet
then we had a representative that top
representative come in to see me State
Department people
and I said here's the story you had to
give us 28 000 soldiers free of charge
to stop people from pouring into the
United States he said he laughed he
thought like what a stupid guy this is
this guy has to be crying sir we
wouldn't even think of doing that why
would we do a thing because they're
coming through your country and you're
not stopping them
in the South they're coming pouring
through in Caravans no you're going to
give it to us no so we're not I said how
much do you want to make a bet
he said we're not going to do it I said
here I have in front of me and I'm going
to sign it right in front of you
a paper this was on a Thursday
or Friday
and I said on Monday morning we're
putting a tariff on all automobiles
coming into the United States and all
other Mexican products coming into the
United States we're putting a tariff of
25 on everyone we're going to make so
much money over and above the cost of
that
and he said you wouldn't do that I said
I'm going to sign it right before your
very eyes watch me sign it and this goes
into effect on Monday morning
[Applause]
and he said to me sir um
do you mind if I take five minutes to
make a phone call he was going to call
obviously the president because he was
the second person
and he came back in three minutes sir
we've decided to give you 28 000
soldiers free of charge
I said but that's not the end we also
want remain in Mexico so that rather
than having people come in and remain in
our country they remain in Mexico until
we approve them until we check them out
find out who they are we don't want
murderers in our country we don't want
Killers we don't want
people that are bad in our country we
don't want gang members
and he said we'll give you that too sir
remain it that's how you think there was
a remain in Mexico you've all heard do
you think that happened just by accident
that happened because of me and then
when Biden came in
he wanted to end it and even the judge
said why are you doing this the judge he
said you can't end it why are you doing
this but it expired at a certain point
as an example title 42 that's to keep
sick people out of the United States
people that are sick
and it was an incredibly successful
thing and they wanted to terminate it
two years ago and the judge said
do you know how many people are going to
be flooding our nation if you determine
this is the judge he's supposed to be
making a rule and he's telling them that
they shouldn't be doing this
and he wouldn't let it happen but it
expired a couple of weeks ago
and they did nothing to
do anything about it and we have a lot
of people that have
diseases that we don't want to have in
our country and I'm not just talking
about covet I'm talking about some big
things
it's so sad and then we terminated Catch
and Release remember the famous you
catch them in our country and then you
release them in our country and we say
come back in four and a half years
we're going to have a child only the
stupid ones come back nobody comes back
four and a half years later they're gone
nobody ever sees them Dan right that's
it I mean how crazy is it it's so crazy
but we ended all of that stuff we had
the greatest border most secure border
we've ever had and the people of this
country want that back you know it's
very interesting when I ran in 2016 the
Border was a big deal I would talk about
the Border
all the time the border the border the
Border people couldn't get enough of it
because we had a really bad unsafe order
people pouring through I did such a good
job that in 2020 nobody wanted to talk
about the border and when I talk about
it people would start falling asleep
I said I did too good a job
but now it's worse than ever it's never
been like this now it's worse than I say
it's worse than any third world country
because a third world country wouldn't
let 15 million people flow through their
borders they'd fight them out with
sticks and cells
[Applause]
so we had the best Border in the history
of our country and now we have in my
opinion the worst Border in the history
of the world think of it what third
world country
would let millions of people just walk
across
the Border take our education take our
hospitals take our food
our veterans aren't treated nearly as
well as illegal aliens our veterans
aren't treated nearly as well
so sad to see
and we had one of the we had the highest
approval rating
Dan knows this of any VA in the country
you know we passed two things number one
we were able to fire people which you
couldn't do for 58 years it was in the
hopper because we had a lot of sadists
we had thieves and a lot of bad people
that worked in the VA bad people but the
worst were to say this they would beat
up old wonderful soldiers beat the hell
out of them they got their jollies out
of it they're sick and we weren't
allowed to fire them no matter what they
did we couldn't fire them I got it so we
fired I think 8 000 about 8 000 people
all sadists and sick people
and
there was one group
just before me they caught him stealing
four hundred thousand dollars Stone Cold
caught them and they couldn't get rid of
them that it came the whole thing is
crazy but we got that done but of equal
importance maybe more importance if you
had to wait more than a day to get
yourself taken care of and we had all
this passed through Congress
if you had to wait more than one day and
you were so helpful
if you had to wait more than one day by
the way Richard has been a fantastic a
fantastic Congressman Richard Hudson
you really helped you really helped us a
lot he was a fighter for this but if you
had to wait more than one day because
people were waiting months they were
becoming terminally ill waiting
something they could clean up with a
prescription or with a small operation
that end up dying that'd become
terminally ill because it would take
four five six months to see a doctor I
said if you had to wait more than one
day you go to a private doctor
and we pay the bill we made deals with
doctors all over the place so they can't
you know they tend to be a little bit
high this is like a golden pot but we
actually saved a lot of money because we
were making people better they were able
to live with their families they weren't
dying it was an incredible thing we had
a 92 percent approval rating
and now it's down the drain because they
ended all that stuff and it's worse than
it ever was before
and then some people will still
foolishly vote for
the Democrats I don't understand it it's
like with religion we fight for religion
they fight against religion how can a
religious person vote for the Democrats
what they've done to Christianity and
all religions
[Applause]
I mean how can they do it
we appointed nearly 300 federal judges
and three great Supreme Court Justices I
fully rebuilt the U.S military we had
more ammunition than at any time
and now we have no ammunition
we have a military missing a thing
called ammunition we had so much it was
stuck to the gills and now we have very
little left
because we're giving it to Ukraine
and I would end at War within 24 hours I
will tell you
it ended fairly
and I impose the powerful travel ban to
keep radical Islamic terrorists and
radical jihadists
the hell out of our country people said
oh that's a terrible thing
but how good did we do in four years
look at our record in four years you
didn't hear about all that stuff I don't
even like talking about it give people
ideas
but we had a tremendous record because
of what we what we passed and we passed
things that nobody thought were possible
but look at our record on that
we accomplished all of this and More in
just four short years and just imagine
what we can accomplish in the next four
years and the advantages that I've been
through it I know the good people I know
the bad people I know weak people and
strong people I know the people that are
losers that you don't want and I know
the people that are winners that a lot
of people don't know or understand
but they're the winners the people that
can bring us back I know them all when I
first went there I didn't I had to rely
on people what do you think of this guy
what do you think of that guy
and people were giving me advice we had
great we had great people too you know
again we rebuilt the military we got all
those tax cuts and regulation because we
had great people but we had some people
that I wouldn't have
put in the place guys like Bill Barr
because he didn't have courage and I
just I wouldn't have put them
I wouldn't have put them in place they
missed a great opportunity
but we have all these people cold we've
caught all of these lies and all of this
corruption
and something has to be done about it
but I know the strong ones and the weak
ones I know the great ones and the ones
that will never be great uh and again
you know it's funny I was in Washington
DC 17 times in my entire life
and most of it was building a hotel down
the road from the White House a
beautiful hotel now I sold it to Waldorf
Astoria but beautiful hotel
and but I was only there 17 times and I
never slept over so I wasn't into that
whole world of Washington establishment
but I learned quickly
I learned very quickly and now I think
I'm into it probably more than anybody
else and I know the people
here's just some of the Bold agenda I'll
put into effect when we become the 47th
president of the United States
[Applause]
before I even arrive at the Oval Office
shortly after I win the presidency I
will have the horrible war between
Russia and Ukraine settled if it's not
already settled and they should get it
done quickly
can't let those people die they asked me
did you see the town hall with CNN
they got one of the highest ratings
they've had in like 11 years and they
end up firing the guy because it was
Trump
instead they should celebrate we had our
highest ratings you're supposed to get
paid for high ratings Richard
but they had one of the highest ratings
they've had in many many years I was on
with a young woman who was I said nasty
she was a very nasty woman but it worked
out very well and they were all going he
owns you he owns you get him off the
heaviest screaming AOC is screaming he
owns you get him off the air stop it
stop
but you'd think if they had high ratings
that would be a big he should ask for an
increase and said they fired him because
I was allowed to put across our point of
view it's our point of view you know we
went into the the womb of the enemy
and I thought actually the reason I did
I thought there'd probably be solid I
tell them because there they are right
there but I tell them that they're doing
so poorly in their readings if they went
to the center or even went a little bit
right of Center and I thought they might
be planning that I think that's a good
business strategy because right now
they're known as fake news can you
imagine if this is on CNN right now
the one thing you know is they're going
to turn it off oh the light just went
off the television it just went off the
red light I can see all those red lights
actually
oh well sorry about that
I'll be finished about this in one like
20 seconds and then you can turn the
light back on
but I thought they were going to be
maybe a little bit more moderate and get
their viewership up and really have a
big evening and great but as I was being
introduced they were saying things that
were so bad I said this is going to be a
war
but it wasn't uh look it worked out well
but it didn't work out well for him it
should have because he actually did a
good job in the sense it was very
professionally done very professional
everything the set everything was
beautiful and they got tremendous
numbers and they fired him he's gone now
Mr Licht sorry about that I'd like to
apologize to Mr Licht
but I'm the only candidate who can make
this promise
I will prevent World War III I will
prevent it
not gonna happen
[Applause]
and we're much closer than you think
right now to having it
and at some point it will happen it will
happen I will prevent it I'm the only
one that can say it I know them all I
know how to deal with them I deal with
them and I'm going to say I know how but
I will get it done I will get it done
did you see the other day Putin said
they are delivering nuclear missiles to
Belarus here we go
and we have a man that has no clue he
has no clue we have a guy that walks
around he has no clue he's like a
walking zombie
you know I meet these other leaders
president XI Kim Jong-un of North Korea
did a great job with that Kim Jong-un
with the meetings and you know historic
and get along great they hate saying
that when they I say they gotta look how
dare you get along great with a dictator
you know a guy's got
hundreds of
nuclear web
and I'm not saying that from weakness
I'm just saying from common sense now I
get along with him great
how dare you say that President XI of
China is a brilliant man
no he's bringing it he leads 1.4 billion
people
and he leads them very powerfully and
he's doing things and ripping off our
country for years
but they get upset when I say somebody's
brilliant but here's what I will say
they're all at the top of their game I
know every one of them all these leaders
they're smart as hell they're tough
they're cunning
some are vicious most of them are
vicious actually
they think the United States is run by
fools
they all take advantage of the United
States I had a thing with France I like
macron but he's a wise guy I like you
know sort of young
and my people were
negotiating with them he's putting a tax
on All American companies that do
business in France I said who the hell
wants to go to France
but he's putting a very big tax on
so Steve mnuchin and my people were
negotiating with them and came back no
they can't make a deal I said why can't
you make a deal we can't they want to
put the tax on all these companies tax
if you're American company they got a
taxi I said that's not right I said give
it another shot they came back a week
later they can't make a deal I said I'll
Make A Deal what do you mean you'll make
it the same thing same old story all the
time it's always the same story they
don't write about it they know about it
but they don't write about it I wish all
these things were taped I really do I
wish these conversations because these
were classic conversations so I got
macron Emmanuel on the phone and I said
Emmanuel
why are you putting a tax on all of our
companies oh but Arnold we have to as
you know it's been approved
by everybody I said I don't care if it's
approved take it off oh no no we can't
do that it's been fully approved and I
said now here's the story if you don't
take it off
again tomorrow morning
it's seven o'clock in the morning we're
taxing all of your wine
and champagne that's coming into the
United States at 100 freaking percent
[Applause]
they'll tell you that's true
no no no no no you cannot do that do not
Donal you cannot do that that is not
fair no no it's not fair that you're
putting this massive tax on American
companies but not others and that's only
because you think we're a stupid country
I said you're not going to do that
Emmanuel tomorrow morning at seven
o'clock 100 on every freaking bottle of
your wine and champagne I don't even
like it I like the stuff
made in our country better
even though I don't drink too much wine
one of my good things not a big not a
big drinker
but no we don't want that Emmanuel no no
no I said yes yes yes you have 10
minutes to call me back he called me
back in three minutes you have a deal
that was here that was the end but you
know what now he's gonna put it back on
so and nobody's gonna you think Biden's
gonna call him back and
talk that way no they don't talk that
way and yet they're vicious I don't even
think it's biting this vicious I think
it's a circle of Maniacs around them you
know you have a woman in the Justice
Department Lisa Monica she's a trump
hater like nobody you've ever seen I
think she's second in the
justice department Lisa Monaco very
unfair you have this Maniac I call him a
deranged person Jack Smith he's deranged
his wife hates Trump even more than he
does
and these are the people we get treated
very unfairly
but I will also so importantly
immediately cancel every open borders
policy of the Biden Administration the
borders will be closed
unless you come in Legally
under Biden other countries are emptying
out their prisons and sane asylums and
mental institutions and dumping everyone
into the United States and you know that
wonderful their prisons are being
emptied out all over the world not just
in Guatemala not just Mexico
not just El Salvador
no all over the world they're coming
last week we had 129 people coming from
129 countries were represented by people
pouring into our country illegally 129
countries most people didn't even know
there were that many they're actually
more than that and sometimes we have a
lot more than that but their prisons are
being emptied into the United States you
go into their prisons they used to have
it so crowded so horrible the people
couldn't lie on the floor they would
stand up and lean against each other
now they have nobody in those prisons
they're all in the United States of
America thank you very much we're like a
Dumping Ground
the same thing with people that are
mentally ill they said please don't use
the word insane asylum but no there are
some very serious places insane asylums
and mental institutions
and those people are all being dumped
into the United States
why should they take care of them if a
country is foolish enough to take the
tremendous risk and cost the risk being
even bigger than the cost but the cost
is not even ma it's not imaginable how
big it is
so we have all these people that are
vicious prisoners you think our
prisoners are bad these people make them
look like Boy Scouts
and they're being dumped into our
country and all of the people who are
mentally ill I read an article recently
fairly recently
about a psychiatrist who was working at
a hospital for 20 25 years in South
America
and he was sitting reading the newspaper
being interviewed for this article
and he said you know I used to work 24
hours a day working with patients but I
don't have patients anymore they've all
been delivered to the United States he
wasn't like complaining it was he was
just saying the facts he said he used to
work so hard now
you know I want to help people but we
really don't have the people are being
led into the United States
and he said some of these people are
very sick
and this is what we're doing
because we have a president that doesn't
have a clue and we have radical leftist
marxists crazy people
that are actually running our country
following the Eisenhower model people
don't realize Eisenhower was very tough
on
immigration did you know that Richard
like very very tough
he had them taken away and he used to
have them brought a little bit over the
border and they'd come back again a
little bit then he hadn't brought 2 000
miles away
and they didn't come back so quick but
they used to put them on the other side
of the Border they'd come right back but
he was very tough but we'll use all
necessary State local Federal and
Military resources to carry out the
largest domestic deportation operation
in American history we have no choice
we have no insurance and I'll probably
lose votes because of that they'll say
oh he's so mean we're not mean they're
killing people they're destroying our
country and if I lose votes that's okay
I don't I don't care we have to do
what's right we have to straighten out
our country I will ask every state and
federal agency to identify every single
known or suspected gang member in
America and every one of them that is
here illegally we will pick them up and
we will send them back to the country
from which they came we'll bring them
back very quickly
because we don't want you or your family
killed by some
deranged person or some
person that's in prison for having
killed nine people and that happens to
be living happily in the United States
of America
and this is very unsuspecting when they
when they hit you you wouldn't even
expect it these are hardened criminals
and to further deter illegal immigration
I will sign a day one executive order
ending automatic citizenship for the
children of illegal aliens
a good automatic solution
automatic citizenship
and unlike Rhonda sanctimonious who
voted to gut Medicare to remember that
he voted to gut it
in Social Security gut Social Security
and he voted three times to raise the
retirement age to 70. you know Rhonda
sanctimonious is a disciple of Paul Ryan
anybody that's a disciple of Paul Ryan
you don't want him
but I will always protect Medicare and
social security for our great seniors
and one thing I've learned in politics
when a guy is against like Medicare or
wants to decapitate it or a guy's
against
anything Social Security
and then they have an election and all
of a sudden they love it although he
hasn't even said that yet
but when they have and you earned it you
know people have been working very hard
for long periods of time there are many
things we can cut you don't have to cut
Social Security you don't have to cut
Medicare if we did the oil thing you
wouldn't have to even think about these
things but they don't want to do the oil
thing because they don't know what
they're doing
but one thing I learned is that what
they want to do it then they go a little
bit because they want to try and get
elected they always go back to it so
when somebody wants to cut
Social Security or Medicare
and then they go back to saying oh I
love them very much
within a fairly short period of time
they'll be cutting it just remember what
I say
and I will not put a national sales tax
of 23 on our citizens which the Sanctus
wants to do
he wants to put a 23 percent national
sales tax on
rich rich people I think I sort of like
the idea for myself
can you imagine somebody now is going to
pay every time they buy something 23
this will not be happy but more
importantly it's not it's not fair on
day one I will immediately sign a new
executive order to cut Federal funding
for any school pushing critical race
Theory transgender insanity
and other inappropriate racial sexual or
political content on our children
[Applause]
it's amazing how strongly people feel
about that you see I'm talking about
cutting taxes people go like that
talking about talk about transgender
everyone goes crazy who would have
thought five years ago you didn't know
what the hell it was
but one that I think is incredible that
we would be saying that I can't even
believe you have to say were apology I
guess I have to exam a politician right
I don't want to say that but I have to
I became president I guess I'm a
politician but I can't believe I say
this I will always support parents
rights can you imagine saying that 10 or
15 years ago parents rights who wouldn't
think of it who wouldn't support parents
rights
that you have to get up and say I will
always support parents rights with their
children I mean what's going on with
their children they can take the
children and do whatever they want
without the parent even knowing
I will not give one penny to any school
that has a vaccine mandate or a mask
mandate
[Applause]
and one of the easiest to me is I will
keep men out of women's sports okay
you see the records that are being
broken now
records that have held up for 18 19
years they're being obliterated
check out the weightlifting records
guy comes up
a woman is fantastic she's a great
Champion she's lifting weights
something like 218 pounds that's a lot
of weight for a woman to go boom
and they'll put like a sixteenth of an
ounce on one side a sixteenth of an
ounce on the other side
yeah
that doesn't quite get there
great Champion then the guy comes along
bingo
I mean they're breaking records by
numbers
but you know what it's honestly it's
really demeaning to women very demeaning
to women so unfair
the swimmers the women female swimmers
they're great incredible people
incredible athletes but they're getting
obliterated these records it's just
getting obliterated
some women are being badly injured by
the wind burn that's caused by the band
going so much faster the wind is blowing
just
it's just terrible you know these
records are being obliterated it's so
unfair but who would even think that you
could allow this who would say that this
is okay
these people are sick they're deranged
outside Allah prohibiting child sexual
mutilation in all 50 states child sexual
mutilation
[Applause]
there's another one though think of it
I think of it I'm going to sign up Bill
prohibited the mutilation of your child
do you think you're supposed to say this
I mean who would have to say this who
would have something where they can
actually do that but they can
because our country has gone cuckoo
ten years ago have you ever said that
they carry out of the room that say what
the hell is this guy talking about today
you have to say it because they actually
they mutilate children
as I announced this week to continue my
long record of standing up to Big Pharma
I will establish a special presidential
commission to investigate what is
causing the decades-long increase in
childhood diseases
autoimmune disorders autism obesity
infertility and other chronic health
problems that people are seeing over the
last nine or ten years that they
they weren't seeing before to uphold our
Second Amendment I will ask Congress to
pass the national concealed carry
reciprocity
[Applause]
and I've always had the endorsement of
the NRA
and I should because I've kept I've kept
it going I've kept our Second Amendment
totally alive we haven't done anything
to
injure it or hurt it and it's been very
hard it's been a hard it's been a very
hard battle but the NRA's always
endorsed me and I appreciate it but I've
done a job that for years I've kept it
alive under the most trying
circumstances we need it for protection
we need it for our safety we need it for
other things too including
sporting
including living but we need it for our
protection and I am a big believer in
the second amendment in a certain
country a man was elected and they're
having tremendous crime out on the
countryside all over this country where
people were going and attacking
households and killing and raping and
doing things that were just absolutely
horrible and he got elected and he said
everybody go out and buy a gun
and they did and now your crime is down
like 40 percent
go out and buy a gun to protect yourself
it's down 40 percent before then you
couldn't you couldn't have any
protection
and the one thing you know the bad guys
are going to have the gun they're not
going to be following the rules I will
protect innocent life just as I did for
Four Strong years nobody did a job like
I did including Roe v Wade bringing it
back to the States
get a great a great thing and remember
that this is a very complex issue
what we've done is we've shown that they
are the radicals not the pro-lifers they
are the radicals because they're willing
to kill a child
seven months eight months nine months
and even after the child is born and
what I did by killing Roe v Wade which
everyone said was impossible number one
we got it sent back to the States and
number two and very importantly I gave
you now the power to negotiate you had
no power before because they were
allowed to do whatever they wanted to do
they could kill the child at any point
including after birth
you look at the governor of Virginia the
ex-governor of Virginia
I call him Michael Jackson you remember
that catastrophe
he said he's a big Michael Jackson fan
that's why he did certain stupid things
but he was willing and he said it you
know put the baby down and we'll decide
with the mother what you want to do
after the baby is born they are the
radicals not Us and nobody wants to see
mutilation or death of a baby after a
certain period of time but I gave you by
getting that by winning that everybody
said it was impossible to win
but we put three great justices out of
the Supreme Court Justices and we now
have you now have the right to a
superpower to negotiate something that's
going to be acceptable before you didn't
have any rights whatsoever they could do
whatever they wanted so it's a very
powerful thing that I was able to get
I'm very proud of it but it goes back to
the States and you're in a very strong
negotiating position actually right now
you're in a much stronger position than
the other side
so it's going to be interesting over a
period of time but it can go fairly
quickly perhaps but there are many
negotiations going on right now that
wouldn't be going I gave you the power
to negotiate at a very high level
and I also have I think shown very
conclusively that they're the radicals
we're not the radicals they are the
radicals so it's very important and it's
very important that it be handled
properly
I will restore a free speech in America
and I will require every federal
employee to pass a new civil service
test demonstrating an understanding of
our constitution
and finally oh look at that wow wow
that's nice
[Applause]
that you believe in the Constitution
that is really something that's great
finally to restore pride in our history
and confidence in our future I will lead
a massive year-long salute to America to
celebrate the 250th anniversary of July
4th
1776 that's the date
we're not changing today
we have a massive anniversary
and our country deserves it especially
what it's going through now this is what
we must do to restore our country to
Greatness the USA is a total mess
our economy is crashing inflation is out
of control
China Russia ran and North Korea formed
together as a menacing and destructive
Coalition nobody thought that would be
possible
it's all taken place over the last two
and a half three years
our currency is crashing and will soon
no longer be the world standard which
will be our greatest defeat in 200 years
this will be
in many ways bigger than losing a war
you will take our power away from us
it'll take everything away from us and
it's happening faster and faster
and it will happen if we're not put
there we have to stop it we have to have
the currency of record
that would be a tremendous failure that
would lead to problems the likes of
which you would never even be able to
think of
but it won't happen with me not even a
chance just like Russia would never have
happened with Ukraine and China would
not have even thought about raiding
Taiwan they're flying bombers over there
every day they have ship circling it
they get ready for something they were
never doing that
in four years one of these gentlemen
standing right there
said well you have to admit nobody
talked about her when Trump was
President that's right
if you took the five worst Presidents in
the history of the United States and
added them up they would not have done
near the destruction to our country as
Joe Biden and the Biden Administration
have done
we are a failing Nation
we are a nation in Decline
and now these radical left lunatics want
to interfere with our elections by using
law enforcement
it's totally corrupt and we can't let it
happen
this is the final battle
with you at my side we will demolish
the Deep State we will expel the war
mongers from our government
we will drive out the globalists we will
cast out the Communists we will throw
off the sick political class that hates
our country
we will roll out the fake news media
we will expose the Rhinos for what they
are
we will defeat Joe Biden and we will
liberate America from these villains
once and for all we will liberate we're
going to liberate our country
the silent majority is rising and under
our leadership
the Forgotten man and woman
will never be forgotten again never be
forgotten again
[Applause]
with your help
with your love your prayers
you have to remember this will
happen this will be a certainty we will
put America First always and that will
lead to the fact
that we will make America great again
greater than ever before thank you very
much North Carolina congratulations to
Mike
but thank you very much
great to be with you thank you